>> Jesse: WELCOME BACK TO THE
SPECIAL EDITION OF HANNITY AND
NOW TURNED BACK TO THE CRISIS AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
WILL THE BIG TRIP TO EL PASO
ACTUALLY IMPROVE ANYTHING?
JOINING US NOW AS FORMER ICE
DIRECTOR IN FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
LOOKS LIKE YOU ARE STANDING IN
FRONT OF THE WALL BACK THERE,
WHAT HAVE YOU SEEN TODAY?
>> I'M DOWN HERE AT THE
BORDER WALL, SOMETHING
KAMALA HARRIS DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
BUT WHAT I'M SEEING HIS MEN AND
WOMEN THAT MAKE UP THIS
COMMUNITY ARE ANGRY BECAUSE THIS
COUNTRY IS IN TROUBLE BECAUSE
THE BORDERS ARE IN CHAOS.
CHERUBS ARE MAKING A POINT, THIS
IS ABOUT IMMIGRATION.
42 DEAD MIGRANTS WITHIN HIS
COUNTRY PUTTING THEMSELVES IN
THE HANDS OF CRIMINAL CARTELS
TALKING ABOUT HIGH-SPEED CHASES
COMING ACROSS THIS BORDER, HERE
WITH ANGEL MOMS AND DADS WHOSE
CHILDREN WERE MURDERED BY
ILLEGAL ALIENS.
OTHER MOMS AND DADS WHO LOST
THEIR CHILDREN TO FENTANYL
OVERDOSES WOULDN'T HAVE HAPPENED
IF WE HAD BORDER SECURITY COMING
ACROSS.
WITH THE BORDER CRISIS LIKE IT
IS, THAT'S WHEN THE CARTELS THAT
THE DRUGS IN HERE AND THAT'S WHY
THE SHERIFFS ARE HAVING SUCH A
HUGE PROBLEM DOWN THERE.
THE STORY NOT BEING TOLD OF THE
VIOLENCE ALL AROUND THE
SOUTHWEST BORDER.
>> Jesse: JUST LIKE YOU SEE
WITH THE DEFUND THE POLICE
SITUATION BRITTLE WE GET TO THE
POINT WHERE YOU WILL SEE
RETIREMENTS AMONG
LAW ENFORCEMENT ON THE BORDER
AND BORDER PATROL AGENTS?
>> I DON'T THINK SO, THEY ARE
AMERICAN PATRIOTS.
THEY ARE ANGRY AND THEY HAVE
ZERO RESPECT FOR THE PRESIDENT,
ZERO RESPECT FOR THE SECRETARY
OF HOMELAND SECURITY.
THEY WILL KEEP DOING THEIR JOB
AND SING THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
SHE SAID RUN CONCENTRATION CAMPS
AND ONE THING SHE DID DO, ASK
THEM BECAUSE OF ALL WORK AND
THEY WOULD SAY YES, IT DOES
WORK.
AND SAID WE HAVE A CRISIS
BECAUSE OF YOUR POLICIES, YOUR
OPEN BORDER POLICIES,
PRESIDENT TRUMP DROPPED
IMMIGRATION BY 80%.
HOW MANY WOMEN DIDN'T CROSSING
ABOUT BORDER, HOW MANY CHILDREN
DIDN'T DIE FROM FENTANYL
OVERDOSES WHEN THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WE HAVE THE
FIRST PRESIDENT IN THE HISTORY
OF THIS NATION THAT IS ACTIVELY
FACILITATING ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION